foreign
[Music]
with FPC tethers when I first reviewed
them last year I was honestly a little
skeptical of them but they've grown on
me in ways that I wasn't anticipating
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of boy spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I want to do an update to
include some of my newer thoughts on pod
POI with FPC tethers but before we dive
in I just want to give you a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyre
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
beckonen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so seriously the weather here in DC has
been acting like a yo-yo for the past
few weeks we've had an 80 degree day we
have had a 30 degree day and uh
fortunately this magnolia tree in the
courtyard here uh the blossoms have
managed to survive all of the cold snaps
and I'm hoping that they will continue
to do so because last year they didn't
fully Bloom they got frozen before they
could and I really really love seeing
the blossoms of this magnolia tree but
let's be real none of you all clicked on
this video in order to hear me talk
about the Magnolias in the courtyard uh
you all came to hear my thoughts on pod
POI with the FPC tethers and to
understand why it's come as kind of a
surprise to me that they've grown on me
it's probably helpful to talk about some
of the misgivings that I had about them
when I first reviewed them
when did I first review them all right
let me look this up right quick I don't
know whether it is encouraging or
discouraging that my performance videos
are coming up in search before the
review but uh
here it is
six months it's been six months since
I've reviewed them so it has been
probably closer to seven or eight months
that have had them period wow time is a
weird thing okay so what exactly was I
skeptical of when I first got those pod
play with FPC tethers I think one of the
big things was that the form factor just
felt odd to me I'd gotten so accustomed
to using pod POI with the really thin
leashes first with a flow cord and then
with the Smithy rope that having thicker
tethers just seems so incongruous to me
it seemed almost counter to the spirit
of the entire prop Point number two I
kind of felt like it changed the form
factor of the prop a lot like
traditionally with pod POI I would
always see them as being kind of these
points of light on the end of a very
very skinny tether and when switching
over to the FPC tethers all of a sudden
the form factor felt to me way more like
sock POI so you could see the full
profile of the tether and again it just
felt so incredibly incongruous to me in
terms of what I was used to with pod POI
and finally some of y'all will remember
that when I first got those tethers I
actually trimmed them down because they
were a little bit long for my tastes and
in the process one of them started to
fray and I was concerned about how
durable they were going to be in the
long term based upon that this is also
kind of a minor quibble but one of the
things that I really liked about the
older tethers for pod POI was that they
wouldn't take up very much room like I
could very very easily get them stuck
inside of my shoulder bag along with my
iPad and a notebook and they would fit
in there just brilliantly the FPC
tethers granted they still fit but it
takes a little bit more effort it's a
minor quibble but it was one that I kind
of like held on to against them okay so
it's now six plus months later and to my
very pleasant surprise
I'm kind of sold on these now like I've
gone back and forth between them and the
older tethers several times now and I
really do prefer the FPC tethers so the
biggest reason just has to do with steel
I am using contact POI I'm using sock
POI all the time and pod POI have always
been on the lighter end of the spectrum
of poi that I use and yet now with the
FPC tethers the weight's a lot more
consistent with what I'm used to and the
wheat distribution is a lot more
consistent with what I'm used to I find
that when I pull out my pod POI that
have the older Smithy rope tethers I
have a little period of adjustment where
I have to kind of retrain myself on
tosses and even just on how the momentum
of the POI operates because well they're
a lot lighter than what I usually
practice with whereas when I pull out
the FPC tethers there's almost no
adjustment which that's kind of cool and
it also has to be said that especially
when it comes to spinning them on video
they just show up a lot better this is
true tethers in general whenever you're
using thicker tethers they show up
better on video and they show up better
on stage and that's not nothing and for
my bellyaching about them taking up a
little bit more room in my bag when I
take them from place to place it's not
really that much more room it's really
important to me to have portable sets of
poi to take around town with me and
definitely when I'm going around after
dark and I think I might want to pull
out a set of LED POI the FPC pod POI are
now my go-to for that also to my
pleasant surprise despite having frayed
the tether when I cut it
after six plus months of heavy usage the
tether really hasn't frayed any more
than that I pretty much only noticed
that when I can feel the texture of it
being a little bit different with one of
the POI tethers versus the other but
aside from that it shows no signs of
breaking down at all and it's funny
because when I first got those POI I
didn't think I was going to be using
them all that much and then the people
of flow toys came back to me and
specifically requested that I do some
performance videos some flow videos
using those specific POI which I thought
was strange because so many of the
videos that I had shot for them were
using their Vision POI and yet if I
hadn't had to keep picking them up and
keep using them I don't know if I would
have gotten here on my own so now I'm
kind of glad that they were so very
choosy on that so yeah I'm gonna say six
plus months on I think the FPC tethers
have officially won me over and become
my favorites and displaced the the old
Smithy wrote pod POI but what do you
think do you own pod POI with Smithy
rope tethers how do you think they
compare to the older Smithy ropes do you
think they're too thick do you have any
concerns about them in the long term or
have you found them to be a surprisingly
good option over time I'm real Curious
leave me a comment let me know and of
course if you'd like to pick up a set of
pod POI with FPC tethers for yourself
you can use my special promo code to get
a discount on your order that code is
drexfactor2023 with a zero instead of an
O use that code to check out and you'll
get a discount on your order thanks to
the fine folks at flowtoys for extending
me that courtesy did you get anything
out of this video please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it to help keep the
conversation going and of course to help
my channel grow
thank you
foreign
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you so very much for supporting my work
and my mission if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter and you
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow watch to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out
some of my LED POI reviews including the
review that I did for those FPC pod POI
I'm going to leave a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this here top video based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a brand new video on Monday
peace